mesdames et messieurs les députés les
échanges en commission ont permis des
débats de fonds et grâce à vous le texte
a été enrichi
en fin de semaine dernière les débats
dans l'hémicycle ont permis des
discussions franches et nourries
cependant lundi lors de l'examen des
crédits de la mission écologique
développement et mobilité durable avec
15 milliards d'euros de dépenses
nouvelles
ponctionné sur des programmes essentiels
vous avez profondément bouleversé la
cohérence et les équilibres du texte
bien sûr nous devons accélérer la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments et
nous le faisons mais mesdames et
messieurs les députés de la nupesse et
du rassemblement national vous le savez
bien on ne peut pas multiplier par 7 du
jour au lendemain les travaux de
rénovation thermique
la rénovation énergétique ce sont aussi
des salariés du BTP que des milliards
d'euros dans le projet de loi de
finances ne permettront pas de former ou
de rendre disponible d'un coup de
baguette magique
la rénovation énergétique ce sont aussi
des matériaux dont l'approvisionnement
d'un certain nombre est déjà en tension
des tensions qui ne pourront pas être
réglées par un amendement au projet de
loi de finances
que les crédits adoptés ne permettent
pas d'atteindre les objectifs que vous
affirmez poursuivre c'est une chose mais
pire par vos votes vous privez les
Français de mesure indispensables pour
lutter contre la hausse des prix de
l'énergie pour protéger leur pouvoir
d'achat
vous ne pouvez pas ajouter 15 milliards
d'euros de dépenses dont la générosité
flirte avec la démagogie sans les
ponctionner sur d'autres politiques
publiques d'autres aides au service des
Français
[Applaudissements]
alors dites la vérité sur quoi avez-vous
décidé de revenir
réunis une nouvelle fois dans une
alliance contre nature la nuit pèse et
le rassemblement national ont aboli le
bouclier tarifaire
dit autrement vos amendements conduit
conduiraient à doubler les factures
d'énergie des Français nous ne pouvons
pas l'accepter
nous ne pouvons pas laisser passer non
plus un vote qui prive nos compatriotes
de Corse et des Outre-mer de tout
soutien pour leur facture d'énergie
[Musique]
ma conviction celle du gouvernement est
celle de la majorité c'est que l'on ne
doit pas opposer transition écologique
et aide à nos compatriotes les plus
modestes c'est qu'on ne doit pas opposer
le climat et le pouvoir d'achat
nous pouvons les concilier et c'est ce
que propose ce texte puisque nous
investissons davantage pour la
transition écologique et que dans le
même temps nous protégeons les Français
face à la hausse des prix de l'énergie
de leur côté les amendements votés
explosent de plein fouet nos
compatriotes à l'inflation
aussi puisque les conditions d'un
dialogue constructif ne sont plus réunis
puisque des mesures protectrices et
attendues ont été balayés dans les
débats puisque le projet de loi est
profondément dénaturé nous devons réagir
aussi aussi sur le fondement de
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement sur la deuxième partie et
l'ensemble du projet de loi de finance
pour 203
le texte que je vous soumets aujourd'hui
n'est évidemment pas identique au projet
de loi initiale un peu de silence s'il
vous plaît
il a été modifié compte tenu de vos
échanges en commission il retient un
certain nombre d'amendements adoptés en
séance notamment lors de la de l'examen
des crédits de la mission outre-mer
c'est un texte qui a évolué aussi en
fonction des urgences et des priorités
dont vous vous faites le relais je pense
aux 7 milliards d'euros supplémentaires
pour la protection des entreprises et
des collectivités face à la hausse des
prix de l'énergie en particulier grâce à
l'amortisseur électricité
je pense aux 500 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires pour le fond vert je
pense au moyen supplément 500 millions
je pense au moyen supplémentaires je
pense au moyen supplémentaires pour une
école inclusive avec la revalorisation
des salaires des aesh
mesdames et messieurs pour le pouvoir
d'achat pour le plein emploi pour
l'égalité des chances pour la transition
écologique et pour notre souveraineté la
France a besoin d'un budget d'un budget
cohérent d'un budget protecteur d'un
budget équilibré je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup madame la Première
ministre
l'Assemblée nationale prend acte de
l'engagement de la responsabilité du
gouvernement conformément au
dispositions de l'article 49 alinéa 3 de
la Constitution le texte sur lequel la
première ministre engage la
responsabilité du gouvernement sera
inséré en annexe au compte-rendu de la
présente séance en application de
l'article 155 alinéa premier du
règlement le débat sur ce texte est
immédiatement suspendu ce texte sera
considéré comme adopté sauf si une
motion de censure déposée avant demain
17h31 et voter dans les conditions
prévues à l'article 49 de la
Constitution dans l'hypothèse une motion
de censure serait déposée la Conférence
des Présidents fixera la date et les
modalités de sa discussion prochaine
séance demain à 15h pour les questions
au Gouvernement la séance est levée